[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
doors ever to think of it dear John and
Hank it's a comedy podcast where me and
my brother John answer your questions
give you a dubious advice and bring you
all the week's news from both Mars and
AFC Wimbledon John how you do it I'm
doing all right
I VidCon has ended which is great
because it's a significant stressor yes
but it's also terrible because I am of
course horrific ly ill are you me too
well it's just the natural course of
being with 26,000 people Hank I don't
know if you know this but until very
recently in human history 26,000 people
were never together no yeah that's
that's really well I mean how what
what's your what's your definition of
recent well if you look at the two
hundred fifty thousand year history of
humans you're looking at about 4% of it
where 26,000 people were together or
could be together
yeah I've been I was very impressed to
know that that like the some of the the
like race arenas in the ancient Roman
Empire I think this was like in the time
of Nero they had they had gatherings of
you know that like rivaled the size of
some of our biggest gatherings yeah but
that was only 1% of human history ago
yes yes correct human history is a long
time indeed would you like a short poem
for today yes I would but first I want
to tell the audience the listeners of
the pod that I have a bad cough so I'm
gonna do my best but if I sound gross or
make bad noises blame viruses not me
Hank I don't want to say that you don't
seem to be at your best right now but
you'd you don't you don't seem I don't I
don't feel like I'm getting a hundred
percent of that Hank Green pod energy
that I come to the pod well you know
John what really gets me going is a
short poem it's a short poems
well this one's about depression and
it's called not so far as the forest by
Edna st. Vincent Millay actually just
part of not so far as the four so as to
keep it short
that chill is in the air which the Y's
know well and even have learned to bear
this joy I know will soon be under snow
the Sun sets in a cloud and is not seen
beauty that spoke aloud addresses now
only the remembering ear the heart
begins here to feed on what has been
night falls fast today is in the past
blown from the dark hill hither to my
door three flakes then four arrived than
many more not so far as the forest by
Edna st. Vincent Millay longtime
favorite poem of mine Hank I even put it
in Looking for Alaska I liked it so much
uh yeah that's that was good I liked
that and also appropriate for the post
VidCon when I am often sick but always
in a little bit of a cannot see cannot
see the sunset because of the clouds
funk do just do - I think psychology and
and coming up coming down off a big high
it's always a wonderful moment when
VidCon is over not because I didn't
enjoy it but because the chances of
something going wrong have reached zero
and it does not reach zero until it's
over but but then the the weeks
afterward I'm always like what what is
life for I'm no longer having that time
alright well there's the news should we
answer some questions from our listeners
Hank yeah sure it hit me hit me with a
question John well Hank we got a lot of
questions this week about sad depressing
terrible thing yes because I don't know
if you've been watching the news but sad
depressing terrible things feel as if
they are everywhere
despite in fact I would argue life on
average for humans not having gotten
dramatically worse this year even though
it feels otherwise I hope I think maybe
yes indeed ha I don't know I'm in a
darkness Hank this question comes from
Meg who writes Dear John and Hank I'm
addicted to reading comments on the
internet Facebook YouTube BuzzFeed I
hate it
yet I can't stop the more I do it the
more frustrated I become there is so
much set online that doesn't need to be
said I love the internet but even within
communities I love like nerdfighteria
there are always going to be people who
use the shield of a computer screen to
hide behind as they write things they
probably wouldn't normally say to a
person's face can we do something about
this or do I just need to give myself an
intervention and stop reading comments
on the internet Meg I think you need to
give yourself an intervention yeah I
don't think that there's anything we can
do to to fight against this particular
tide in the near term I think there may
be an eventual solution which is that
everyone realizes that this isn't making
them happy right but it will have to be
a structural solution Hank I don't think
that it's going to happen right now now
I am actually thinking pretty seriously
for the first time in many years of of
really structuring my internet life so
that it is more pleasant and less Rickon
terrible yeah yeah I it has gotten bad
and I also I don't want to say that I
never want to say that like the Internet
is the cause of some of some problem
that I'm seeing in society but it does
seem as if finally the filter bubble is
catching up with us and and just and
lies and misinformation are running
rampant on every side and it's creating
sort of deep dissatisfaction not so much
with the world as with each other and
but also with the world and it's making
everyone feel as if they are unheard and
that they are the only sane voice in a
room full of insanity and it makes me
want to disengage in a way that I have
never wanted to disengage I think
disengaging might be the right decision
Hank I really do I think it might be
time to say you know what like I can't
do this anymore and I'm not sure that my
participation in these spaces is helpful
like I'm not I know it's not help
to me but I'm also no longer sure that
it's helpful to anyone right I mean I
think that there there are helpful
places to be but I think that it is very
you have to be very aware of the
neighborhood's you go to because there
are certain ones that are destructive to
the self so long story short Meg we
completely endorse you having an
intervention with yourself no longer
reading the comments I mean I think
that's the the least you can do and then
you have to have a long talk with
yourself about how and whether you even
want to participate in the existing
social media models because I think
right now at least for me they feel
pretty broken so if you see less of me
on Twitter that's why all right we we
will not disengage from the entirety of
the Internet there are many spaces that
we do enjoy however I know I'm still
gonna be making vlogbrothers videos
every Tuesday and dear Hank and John as
far as I know is still not available on
vinyl so I'm gonna have to stick with
podcasting as well
dude we should do a vinyl release oh
yeah that's a great idea Hank that's
that's exactly what this podcast needs
to finally achieve financial stability
should do it though for the project for
awesome we should do a special vinyl cut
this would do well a special vinyl only
episode of dear Hank and John that is a
dope idea you have to agree with me
first off I want to go back in time to
the time before you tried to sound hip
and cool and young by using dope as an
adjective secondly that is a pretty dope
idea all right here's another questions
from Nev who asks dear Hank and John I
need to know it has long been bugging me
our bell peppers airtight are they
waterproof how did air get inside them
when they were growing is there just a
vacuum inside of them until we slice
them open please help me what a great
question and I mean I want to live
inside of this person's consciousness
for a while because they're interesting
and very curious and they they clearly
have the kind of life that I want to
have where you're paying attention to
the details of existence and I also have
no
frickin idea of the answer yeah I had to
google this but I did and the answer is
that there are so leaves and plant
tissues of all kinds have to let oxygen
and other other gases diffuse into them
just for the processes of photosynthesis
so the bell peppers have stoma on them
that allow gases to diffuse and they can
open or close those stoma as they wish
and they actually let gasses diffuse
into them as they grow and they can and
then after they grow after they reach
full size they actually get covered in
this wax that prevents prevents gas
exchange and prevents you know pathogens
from getting into those thin to those
vulnerable areas so that that's how it
works other so they are airtight
they are airtight after you buy them but
airtight is a weird thing because
because diffusion happens you know
through through membranes that we would
consider to be airtight like a balloon
for example you think of that as
airtight but if you leave it around for
long enough eventually it deflates
because there is some diffusion
happening across that membrane it just
takes a very long time and smaller
molecules do it faster than bigger
molecules which is why helium balloons
will deflate faster than balloons you
blow up with the oxygen and nitrogen in
your lungs and also that's why that's
why they so will sometimes seal your
tires up with nitrogen instead of oxygen
and nitrogen because nitrogen will take
less will diffuse more slowly than the
atmospheric gas which contains more
stuff than just a nitrogen so you really
don't want to fill up your car tires
with helium no that would be bad though
an interesting and fun experiment I
would be interested to see how much less
my car weighed if I filled my tires up
with helium and someone that's what I
would love to see someone doing that
math yeah but this yeah I had to look
this up for sure but it would be
interesting it'd be super cool if there
was a vacuum in there and you cut you
cut it open and it was like pop like it
was some kind of like suddenly all the
air rushed into the pepper but
that's not what happens well Hank you
got to answer a question from one of
your areas of expertise now I'm going to
answer one from one of my areas of
expertise this question comes from uh
Boone in Norway who writes dear John and
Hank I remembered John mentioning that
he's quit smoking in the past I am now
20 years old and have been smoking for
close to three years and I'm finding it
difficult to quit
I would like to quit for a multitude of
reasons yep I agree obviously but when
the craving kicks in all those reasons
dissipate and I was wondering if you
could share some tips that worked for
you and how you stopped Hank I know of
very few people who have quit smoking as
many times as I have quit smoking I am
an expert in quitting smoking and then
about 12 years ago I had my first
experience with staying I had about 12
years ago I had my first experience with
remaining a quitter
and I have not smoked since then so I've
only successfully quit once but I've
failed at quitting many many many times
the number one thing that I would say is
that for me the key was Nicorette Hank
do you remember like the five year
period where I chewed Nicorette yes very
very vividly oh I just I mean I I came
to like Nicorette much more than I ever
liked cigarettes
um quitting Nicorette was the real
challenge but Nicorette is so much
better for you than smoking so I do
think that like it's not that it comes
without health risks because there are
health risks to nicotine itself but it
is way better for you than all the stuff
you put in your lungs when you smoke
cigarettes so I would encourage you to
use the patch or use Nicorette or use
any kind of crutch that works for you
there is no shame in using a crutch I
don't even think there's any any shame
in chewing Nicorette for years like I
did you know who chews Nicorette Hank no
the President of the United States of
America Barack Obama there you go there
you go longtime Nicorette you're also
apparently still sometimes smoke
cigarettes it's very very hard to quit I
don't want to minimize how hard it is
but it is possible I actually think it's
harder when you're younger I tried to
quit smoking when I was about 20 as well
and I did successfully quit for about
ten months but I ended up going back to
it and as I got older even though my
addiction was sort of a longer-term
problem I found it easier to quit I
think psychologically but I would
encourage you just to use crutches don't
be afraid of that I think that's fine
so when the craving kicks in instead of
having a cigarette you chew a piece of
nicorette and then you can worry about
the Nicorette problem in a couple years
all right
god that's dubious advice yeah yeah a
little bit dubious but but better than
better than the alternative I've got
another question from Clara who asks
dear Hank and John I've been in my first
job since graduating college for about
one year I just volunteered for a new
team on this team I get to write blog
posts and make infographics the problem
is that the team leaders want to publish
the work I do under the name of a
co-worker who is the lead of the team
they say they don't want to confuse the
audience with who is writing the content
and they want a single point of contact
the team lead is also a fairly new
graduate and has been at the company for
only a couple weeks longer than me so I
know it's not about seniority or
authority on the subject is it wrong for
me to not want my work published under
someone else's name I wouldn't have a
problem if it was just posted under the
company's name without someone specific
attached to it but I can't get over the
feeling that I don't want my writing
attributed directly to someone else
should I get over it and just contribute
anonymously to the team or should I
insist that my name gets published with
my work I mean I would insist that a
different name gets published with the
work like I think it's ludicrous that
someone else an actual human being is
being credited with your writing yes if
they want to have a single point of
contact and not confuse the readership
then you've got to invent a person
everybody knows that yeah you you you
either invent a person or you just
create an info at whatever dot-com email
address like this is pretty unacceptable
yeah by the way how bad do you never
want to work at a company where there
are teams and team leads I mean we have
kind of teams and team leads at my
company
no no no no no no any time somebody in
this office uses the word team I shushed
I like teams teams are good
the people who work together it makes me
physically sick well what makes me more
physically sick is the idea of someone
writing some something and someone else
getting there some other human getting
their name on it because they're the
lead of the team like that is there yeah
you clearly you need to invent a
pseudonym and then give them a full rich
complicated life as I have given Leon
Moss at Twitter user Leon must number
for Earth you know you've gotta like
give someone a rich and complicated
backstory so that you can have a proper
fun pseudonym Bank in fact without
revealing like too much of a secret I
have worked under the name of a
pseudonym who I have given in my mind a
complicated backstory and who at at
least at one time had an email address
and answered email from that email
address etc and I was totally
comfortable with it I'm not opposed to
being dishonest with your readers
I'm just opposed to someone being
credited for your work like down the
road if that's under their byline are
they gonna like claim it when they're
applying for their next job it's just a
very weird situation yeah I mean it it
it just does not make any sense at all
either there should be no name or fake
name but a real person should not be
getting credit for the work that you are
doing Clara and I don't know how to
solve that problem except to have your
co-workers listen to this podcast
yeah just like really subtle ease be
like you know what my favorite podcast
is it's called dear Hank and John
they've got a new episode out that it's
just really funny
John reads and Edna st. Vincent Millay
poem Hank has no energy it's great you
should really listen to it
yeah just but but just for the first
like 1/4 of the podcast that beaker I
just make sure that you make it to like
minute 30 just in case there's anything
that's like real relevant to our
particular interest but I mean not like
I submitted a question or anything by
the way sorry for using your real name
Clara I mean I don't feel bad calling
these people out at all
that is not how it works yeah that's
that's not how it works
speaking of not how things are supposed
to working
we got about 75,000 questions about
exit yeah how do you want do you want to
read an at one of one of the questions
sure this one comes from Ray who writes
Dear John and Hank I'm a UK citizen and
I'd like your dubious advice on the
following topic how do you react when
your democracy makes a decision probably
a permanent one that you deeply disagree
with right now I'm just feeling anguish
and frustration as well as an
overwhelming sense of powerlessness
how do I escape this spiral well Ray the
good news is that soon you will be
asking yourself an even more important
question which is how do I escape this
spiral of deflation and increase debt
that my country chose for itself when it
decided to exit the European Union I'm
just kidding right it's possible that
this won't be as bad as everyone worries
it will be you know Norway for instance
has a really good relationship with the
EU without being technically part of it
so if there's a Norway style solution to
the UK's exit from the EU I don't think
it will be catastrophic
but that would require a lot of the
things that the leave vote was voting
against including free movement of
people and I share your concern and I
don't know what to tell you the other I
would also say ray that the feeling of
anguish and frustration and the
overwhelming sense of powerlessness is a
part of democracy and it is the way that
50% of the population of your country
would be feeling if you had if if your
side had won and that's always a very
difficult thing to appreciate and feel
especially when you know we we are so
certain of our rightness and I'm not
saying that I'm not certain of your
rightness I am but for example we have
had a lot of people in the US feeling
tremendously disenfranchised and
powerless because now people have rights
that sit like that like gay people have
the right to marry and my country
where they didn't and people feel like
that is a betrayal of their values and
that their voice isn't being heard and
that makes them more and more angry and
disenfranchised and and feeling like
feeling like their perspective does not
matter and that and it really is a part
of and like every time a vote has not
gone my way I have that feeling but it
is important to recognize that more
important than winning any election is
the idea of democracy and the success of
democracy and and sort of the the beauty
of that system getting and I think that
that helps me like believing in the
system of democracy not not in America's
system of democracy but the idea of
democracy helps me get over that feeling
of you know as you put it anguish and
frustration and powerlessness don't
agree with you about this particular
vote because this is not a vote that
should have occurred this is not a thing
that should have been put to a vote and
I think part of the frustration is that
one particular historical moment became
incredibly important because the
particular population alive at that
moment was allowed to vote about
something that had broad repercussions
both for people who are yet I just III
don't think it ever should have been
allowed to come to a vote there are lots
of things in a democracy that we don't
vote on there are reasons that we have a
representative democracy instead of
direct democracy and I don't agree that
this is an example of democracy working
to me this is an example of you know
populism at its at its worst at its most
dangerous and I absolutely feel the same
way about the denial of Rights to people
like that should not be something that
we vote on we shouldn't vote on whether
or not we can deny people entry into
this country based on their religion we
shouldn't vote on whether or not people
should be able to get married
the person that they love yeah III think
it's a weird difficult time and I think
the Internet is part I know we don't
like to blame the Internet for problems
I'm not blaming the Internet for the
problems but I think the Internet is
part of the issue I think the
echo-chamber that we're all living
inside of has made it very difficult for
us to see the other well and that
includes me not understanding really not
having a good understanding of the
arguments in favor of for the UK leaving
the EU it's not my decision it's not my
country I understand that but I do not
think that it should have been put to a
vote perhaps we should move on to
another question yeah I don't know if we
have helped Rea at all or anyone
no we haven't helped Rea there's no
helping Rea it gets better with time and
hopefully the actual repercussions will
be less dramatic than the repercussions
that we all fear I think that's the
other thing is that a lot of times
things aren't as bad as they seem
nor are they as good as they see them
you know it's it's always somewhere in
the middle yeah and there's nothing
wrong with incremental human progress
and sometimes things go down and then
but the goal is that the the march of
human progress is is one that you know
life gets better forever for everyone on
average which has happened and has
happened yeah I think the long arc of
history still definitely points toward
unity I mean it was only not to get too
much into like broad historical context
but twenty-five thousand years ago you
know most most groups of human beings
numbered in the dozens not in the
hundreds not in the thousands not in the
millions and certainly not in the
billions and so over the last twenty
five thousand years we've seen again and
again that humans unify when they have
the opportunity to they go to cities
when they have the opportunity to even
when it frankly doesn't make sense for
them to be in cities they go to cities
they people want to be with each other
they want to be in ever larger groups
they want to be better connected to more
people and over
I think that will continue to be the
trend and I think that has been good for
the species and I think it will continue
to be good all right
we have another question from Barker who
asks dear Hank and John I'm in Europe
for a summer abroad and I've noticed
something tomatoes in the old world
taste so much better than tomatoes in
the United States I hate Tomatoes at
home won't eat them on anything but here
I could probably just eat a couple raw I
was wondering if there was a scientific
explanation like the environment they
were cultivated in or is it just because
my environment has changed is it all in
my head well it's important to note that
Tomatoes did not exist in the old world
until there was a new world because
tomatoes are a food from the Americas
yes that is that is important to note
the other other thing that you are
noticing is that in the US we have we
mostly eat tomatoes that are very
specific varieties of tomatoes that are
very easy to cultivate and mass
quantities and they're very durable and
they're very symmetrical and pretty and
they look good on grocery store shelves
and they last a long time and there are
other varieties of tomatoes that we
don't see as often that taste very
different and have much more taste and
aren't just sort of a watery sourness
which isn't nothing I like a tomato like
an American tomato on my on my hamburger
but but heirloom tomatoes as they call
them these older varieties of tomatoes
or varieties of tomatoes that are I
wouldn't we say older they're not
necessarily an older species they're
just what people used to grow before
more industrialized forms of Agriculture
they're harder to grow but they have
much more flavor and are they just eat I
am totally with you and I had this exact
some experience not when I went to
Europe but when I moved to Montana where
they grow these tomatoes and you can get
them at the farmers market and they are
delicious it's ridiculous I had no idea
yeah I don't think Parker is eating the
tomatoes in my garden because the
tomatoes in my garden are 10 out of 10 I
mean I'm like a different a
fundamentally different food
than the tomatoes that I buy on the
grocery store shelf so I definitely
think come back to the United States and
enjoy our many varieties of heirloom
tomatoes Parker and you will be glad to
be an American again yeah I mean you
won't have health care there are a few
other problems that we haven't solved
but we've got this tomato thing down
yeah all right god glad we had a good
answer for that question at least Hank
we've got another question this is an
important one and it comes from Taylor
who asks Dear John and Hank I'm just
sitting here breastfeeding my brand-new
two week old baby and wondering why is
it that newborn babies smell so good
is it just because I'm a mom that I
enjoy that distinctly Swedish baby smell
or is something science here going on
here well Taylor I cannot tell you if
something science he is going on but I
can tell you that nothing smells better
than a baby until and unless they poop I
mean I remember my dear friend Shannon
who I've talked about on the pod before
after my son Henry was born
Shannon was like I need to get to see
Henry in the first few weeks and I was
like why you know it's not really doing
much and she was like because nothing
smells as good as a fresh one and she's
right there is nothing nothing smells as
good as a fresh baby there's just it's
just an amazing thing they just you want
to be with them all the time and I do
think probably ultimately something
science here is going on there because
it is the smell of the baby that makes
the otherwise unbearable bearable well I
can tell you that two things one we
don't know what the smell is we don't
know what the smell is composed of where
it comes from if it's like a leftover
thing from like the sort of the wax that
covers a baby upon birth and if that
gets washed off but maybe there's a
little bit of it left or if it's a if
it's a consequence of the degradation of
that wax by microbes or if it's produced
from the sweat glands of the baby but we
do know that that smell has a cognitive
effect upon people who smell it this
study has only been
women it's been done on both mothers and
people who have not had kids and and in
both groups but more strongly and
mothers it has an effect on the brain
that is very similar to the effect that
dopamine has and it creates bonding it
is it and it also just is to sort of
like a pleasurable sensation so we do
know that that smell which only lasts
for a few weeks is a does have a
measurable cognitive effect on the brain
of humans so that's pretty cool so I
don't want to oversimplify this or
anything Hank but you're basically
saying that like babies smell like
heroin feels yeah a little bit
I I mean I'll tell you what I I do not
want to have another child
I found having babies to be extremely
difficult and I didn't even have to have
them and yet there nothing smells like a
freshie well the good news is John that
if you want to get that sensation back
all you have to do is go out get some
heroin alright John this one is from
Cory who asks dear Hank and John I'm
currently an animation major who loves
the world of character design lately
I've been lucky enough to be hired on
several different projects developing
and illustrating characters a lot of the
people in my life are supportive of my
goal to work in the art industry but
there are still a good amount of people
who see my work as just a hobby and
constantly asked when I'm gonna get a
quote real job how do I explain to these
people that my freelance work is a real
job personally I'd like to shove my
money in their face while yelling see
look at the money that I earned from my
quote hobby but I don't think that would
be socially acceptable yeah so I mean
for many years when we especially after
we moved to Indianapolis people assumed
that Sarah sort of provided for me with
her work at the Museum while I had this
hobby writing books that no one read and
making YouTube videos which was not a
thing that you could turn into money and
it did bother me at first but then
something switched inside of my brain
and I realized that I was making
my life and my self-worth about what
other people thought of my work rather
than just doing the work like I remember
my my neighbor after the first time I
mowed the lawn I was really excited to
mow a lawn Hank because I grew up with
dad mowing the lawn and I thought you
know now I'm gonna be a proper adult who
mows their own lawn and everything and
my neighbor came up afterwards and I was
just drenched in sweat because it turns
out that I'm not well suited to mowing a
lawn surprisingly enough and he said you
know when the Kaufman's lived here this
was the best lawn in the neighborhood
and I was like wow they don't live here
now and he was like and it seems like
you've got time to take care of it
dot-dot-dot and it did hurt my feelings
but I was giving them way too much power
like if you get to live your dream and
make money it doesn't matter why do you
have to prove to these people that you
live your dream and make money yeah it's
fine just live your dream and make money
congratulations on like winning the
absolute life lottery yeah I mean I'm
very happy for you Cory that's really
fantastic and I want to see some of your
work and what a cool thing to get to do
and if this is one of the prices that
you pay for your job then that's one of
the prizes you pay is that because like
I think most of the time when you're
when you're meeting somebody and they
ask you what you do and you say you do
freelance character design for for
animation like for animated things
people will be like oh that's cool tell
me more about that and that's that's
great
they're not gonna be like that's not a
real job and I I think that the people
who don't who are wondering when you're
gonna get a real job just maybe have a
different conception of how life is
supposed to be than you do and that's
fine and it's but it's fine to have that
difference today's podcast is brought to
you by not having what some people
consider to be a real job not having
what some people consider to be a real
job downright pleasurable today's
podcast is also brought to you by
heirloom tomatoes not just available in
Europe also in America they're like
tomatoes except they taste and today's
podcast is brought to you by Clara Clara
I wrote all of that stuff that's being
attributed to Sara and finally is
podcast is brought to you by putting
helium in your car tires putting helium
in your car tires it will make your car
way slightly less which will make it
more efficient even if your tires
suddenly and rapidly deflate all right
Hank slightly related question how big
of a monster truck would I need to have
in order to build a floating car like if
I filled the tires with helium and I
want the the car to just float all the
way to the stratosphere how big do the
tires have to be can we just say off the
ground because atmospheric pressure
changes a lot as you get up into the
stratosphere and that would make the
tires have to be immeasurably different
sure I really just need to be I want to
build a I want to build a hover monster
truck with helium tires all right well I
don't know the question to that answer
yet but I bet somebody will maybe help
us do that math I also don't know the
question to that answer you're really
not bringing your A game today
I'm bringing my C game I mean I've
actually been pretty impressed by my my
ability to do this earlier this morning
I couldn't go I couldn't go like five
seconds without coughing so I'm quite
pleased oh man I just I can't stop
thinking about how good babies smell I
just ah babies babies are amazing they
are just absolutely the thing that gets
me most about babies is that despite
having essentially none of the things I
associate with humaneness they're little
people they're like tiny little human
beings yeah I don't know man I'm getting
a little baby crazy Hank we need to
answer another question I can't believe
this podcast wasn't brought to you
anyone by baby smell but I guess nothing
smells like a fresh one like a fresh one
let's let's answer this question from
Nicholas Hank you're at
Dear John an egg pertaining more toward
Hank I've been wondering what to call
your style of music I went to one of
your concerts about a month ago and I
brought a date but she and her friends
would ask me what type of music you'd be
playing prior to the concert and I was
never able to come up with a clear
answer you frequently called yourself a
punk rocker but I've never really
associated your music with punk rock I'd
like to think you and bands such as
herring the Potters have created a type
of sub-genre called nerd Punk similar to
pop punk and I now refer to your music
as nerd Punk do you accept this term as
valid and John how would you describe
Hanks music style
you go first quick sidenote okay quick
sidenote
ank you're set at VidCon 2016 was not
just the best 30 minutes of music I've
ever heard you play it was like among
the best 30 minutes of music I've ever
heard anyone play it was I don't want to
sound paternalistic or like I didn't
used to like your music but it was so
much better than you were in 2008 or in
2012 when we toured together it was like
you were doing a fundamentally different
thing than the thing that you were doing
a few years ago it was beautiful to
watch well it's very nice to have to
have a band and I've seen you play with
that band before usually it is not that
yeah we it was a very tight set we just
got off tour so we've done that a very
similar set a bunch of times and we have
a really good time and it's funny
because I in in the work up to that you
don't know this John and the work up to
that to that set I had gotten what what
might if you were not an adult would be
considered diaper rash quite madly at
walking around VidCon just due to due to
that the the the life that is Hanks and
so I that during that in that entire set
was quite painful
but I had really had gotten some
medicated cream thanks to thanks to my
assistant Julie thank you but yeah it
was so so I really I had to work through
the pain maybe that was good for that
maybe that was good for them for the art
maybe it was you were you you were
moving quite freely I mean I always
forget that you you are a good dancer
because you would think that because we
are so closely genetically related that
we would have something in common and
yet we don't I really don't you can
dance you can sing you know science it's
like we are wholly opposite people we're
all your music nerd funk I like that I
like that label I also often go with
nerd punk I I think that it is it is
yeah I often have a hard time describing
it myself but nerd Punk is fine and I
think the best way to do it in two words
all right Hank we need to answer one
more question before we get to the
all-important news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon huge news out of AFC Wimbledon
this week Hank Oh big news from Mars as
well this one is from Elle who asks dear
Hank and John I've only ever lived in
port towns and I've only ever spent time
in port towns tell me in landlocked
cities what constitutes downtown and by
City downtown is always around the
harbor and is often the oldest part of
town in a place with no harbour what's
the place marker for downtown is it a
river a park a very large shoe I'm very
confused about this how is there a
downtown with no harbour please help
yeah I mean there are some Midwestern
cities where I feel like the downtown
was created more or less at random yeah
you know like there was all like there
was one store there and a street and
somebody built the second store and then
a third store and then a tenth store and
then you had your downtown but in
Indianapolis the whole city is built
around the White River because the the
planners of the city believed that the
White River was going to be you know
similar to what the Chicago River is in
in Chicago but in fact the
River is only like six inches deep so
it's a totally non navigable river and
turns out to have been a completely
useless body of water from a commercial
perspective and yet the downtown is all
sort of structured around it nonetheless
but yeah I think it's usually around
bodies of water in fact as you know Hank
Indianapolis was for many years the
largest city in the world not on a
navigable waterway so I think it usually
it is it is some body of law yeah
and often times it is the intersection
of two large streets
it can also be where the railroad depot
was built in my town it is sort of both
of those things so there's there's the
railroad where the railroad old railroad
station was and then there's and then
there's where the river is and there the
the road that went from the railroad
station to the river is sort of how
downtown happened but yeah it's always
different things but it always it almost
always is indeed the oldest part of the
city unless it's a it's like a sort of
suburb that's being built and they sort
of constructed downtown through very
intentional urban planning right like if
you go to celebration Florida the town
built by Disney there's a downtown there
but it's just it's made up well I guess
all things are made out but it was made
up all at once which makes it feel more
made up that yeah but no I've never seen
a town built around a very large shoe
not yet but the arc of history is long
and it does bend toward shoes Hank what
is the news from Mars this week well uh
it's so hard to pick we had two really
big Mars News's this way what do you do
John when you have when you have two two
big AFC Wimbledon News's just tell me
both of them I'm excited okay let's do
all the news so first Mars was once much
much more oxygen-rich than we thought
which is a bit of a mystery
so curiosity has done some new chemistry
on some new rocks that we could tell had
some interesting properties but we found
a bunch of manganese oxide and that
stuff can only form through two
mechanisms one it can be formed by
microbes or two it could be formed in
the presence of both a lot of water and
a la
a lot of oxygen so obviously there there
must have been a more oxygen than there
currently is on the surface of Mars
because it's covered in iron oxide and
which is what gives it's that rusty
color and and iron oxide is as you might
expect from the name composed partially
of oxygen so so but the the manganese
oxide requires much more oxygen to form
than iron oxide which means that there
was a period in Mars's history when
there was a ton of oxygen and we've had
some thought in the past that the
presence of oxygen is impossible without
life but we we you know the immediate
thought is like well how else could we
explain this and and the current
explanation for how Mars once had both a
bunch of water and a bunch of oxygen is
that when it's magnetic field first shut
down and and the sun's like you know
high-energy sunbeams could finally hit
the surface without being interfered
with there was a bunch of water on the
surface of Mars those high-energy you
know at high-energy radiation hit the
surface of Mars and broke much of the
water molecules apart into hydrogen and
oxygen
the hydrogen being very light it's you
know the lightest of all the elements
was able to float up higher into the
atmosphere which where it was pushed
away out of the atmosphere of Mars by
the solar wind the oxygen was then left
behind that's very interesting because
oxygen is a very reactive compound it
could actually be quite negative a
negative consequence for the potential
for life because it can break down I
think you know we call it oxidizing it
can break down complex molecules very
easily and quickly however it can also
be utilized by life very effectively
allowing for a great deal more
interesting chemical processes that
wouldn't be possible without life which
is why there was sort of a life
explosion when when life on Earth first
started utilizing oxygen after it had
been produced through biological
conditions so almost all of the oxygen
on earth is produced by
and then is consumed by animals and
animals weren't really possible on earth
until plants had created a huge amount
of oxygen in the atmosphere so that's
very exciting news that tells us maybe
something about Mars's history and and
also you know like having this period of
time where there was a lot of water and
a lot of oxygen shows us a potential
Mars in the past that was very very
similar to earth Wow
so just just to clarify this here
there's gonna come a day probably in the
next like ten years but we don't know
when when the solar winds will just blow
away Earth's atmosphere and then like
whatever if there are some kind of
people eventually in the future they're
going to be thinking about and talking
about earth the way that we are
currently thinking and talking about
Mars well let's hope not our magnetic
field seems to be pretty robust so let's
hope that it sticks around for a while
and that we don't have all of our all of
the water on Earth split into into into
gases that we can can no longer drink or
bathe in if Mars was really like Earth a
long long time ago
is there a possibility that fairly
complex life evolved on Mars a long long
long long time ago and of course we
don't have any record of that yeah there
is you know and like potentially
multicellular life certainly not a lot
of people hold on to the to the hope
that there was like advanced life like
maybe even what we would consider like
civilizations that's not a thing we
would see evidence of that but it's
possible that there was we though if it
was millions and millions of years ago
yeah I mean yeah yeah
like if it was anything like our our
civilizations but of course maybe it
wasn't anything like our civilizations
but but the possibility that there was
you know it's it's all it's always very
weird when you're talking about life on
other planets because if it was based on
entirely different chemistry's if it was
based on you know and like not based on
you know DNA and RNA like our life is
it becomes very difficult to even know
what that would look like or how to look
for it and and yeah so so right you know
like when when I say like multicellular
life like maybe life didn't even exist
in a way that we would consider to be
cellular or multicellular so it's very
difficult to say but yeah it's
absolutely possible that life life
existed on Mars yeah I mean I think
about the fact that we don't really know
much about the human human species that
predated Homo sapiens you know we know
very very little about them despite
sharing a planet with them and it not
being that long ago we only have a
fossil record that we wouldn't have
access to if we could only see the
surface of the planet
so I don't know maybe yeah I mean like
it yeah life can have a pretty
substantial impact on a planet I don't
know what you're talking about humans
haven't had a substantial impact on this
planet at all we're doing fine
everything well I mean not just humans
but you know the the you know the way
that like the sort of whole planet
biology of Earth has affected the
chemistry of the Earth's surface is
affected you know the you know how how
erosion happens like effects that it
actually affects the geology of the
planet as well it affects both the
composition of the planet and the
structure of the planet and it would be
you know I I wouldn't know what a planet
that had life a whole life ecosystem and
then didn't have it anymore would look
like but my guess is that that would be
an easier thing to detect than the kind
of you know more algae mat kind of life
row that that was very prevalent on
earth for a really long time right
well Hank before advanced life happens
this all sounds like it's gonna be
really interesting stuff for the first
humans on Mars to explore in 2028 the
other news is that is that Mars that
NASA actually just tested its gigantic
biggest ever solid rocket booster that
will be if all goes to plan B the solid
rocket booster that takes humans to Mars
and they are planning on that happening
sometime in the 2030s
so not no help for me oh that's great
news I can't wait for the 2030s and all
of the Mars stuff we do then Hank the
news from AFC Wimbledon very very
exciting
Wimbledon have signed one of the they're
big signings of the summer a new winger
named Chris
welp Dale hopefully will be saying his
name a lot this season Chris welp Dale
you'll never guess where we signed him
from Hank was it from from Welk Delton
no it was from your beloved Stevenage oh
my goodness sorry Steven we showed up to
Stevenage and we just ransacked the
place and we left with Chris welp Dale
so Stevenage stuck in league too for
another season which means thank you
won't even get to hear the news from
Stevenage twice twice this season
because we'll be playing the likes of
Swindon Town yeah Chris welp Dale is
gonna be playing in Ligue 1 next season
for AFC Wimbledon the third tier soccer
team sponsored by nerdfighteria and
sponsored by this podcast indirectly
really everything that we do at this
point goes to sponsor AFC Wimbledon so
yeah we're gonna be rooting for Chris
Whelpdale go Chris alright John what do
we learn today well we learned that
nothing smells as good as a fresh one
yeah we learned that nicorette gum has
only one of the toxic chemicals that
will destroy your life that while
smoking has has hundreds or even
thousands we learned that Hank plays
nerd punk music and plays it
astonishingly well ah and we and we
learned that if you're writing a thing
and someone else's name is on it that's
not cool that's not cool no that's a
problem that's an issue it's time to
invent a new person who can share the
both of you
all right John thanks for podcasting
with me today I hope that next week you
bring your a-game with somebody else
because I'm gonna be on vacation for two
weeks Oh ma'am me and somebody else or
possibly no one including not even me
yeah we might take a week off depends on
depends on how things fall out depends
on how long I feel like I've been
destroyed by by foreign invaders inside
of my body oh those are the worst
invaders well no no there are they're
worse invaders I've read I've read
somewhere I've seen some world history
thanks for podcasting with me thanks to
Nick Jenkins for editing today's
high-quality podcast we really killed it
on two consecutive episodes Hank
gunnarolla wrote our theme music our
intern is Claudia Morales
rosianna halse rojas helps out with
questions thank you again for listening
and as we say in our hometown don't
forget to be awesome and you can email
us at Hank and John at gmail.com ah
right you can email as a Hank and John
at gmail.com anybody who made it to the
end of the podcast should get back a
privileged email address but that's the
only one Hank and John at gmail that's
us all right thanks for listening bye
bye
[Music]
you